trans athletes have an unfair advantage
of course not why would they what is a
woman
a woman is having a vagina oh well
actually knows whatever
who are now capable of giving birth does
questioning make you transphobic I'm
homophobic I'm transphobic
today I asked about trans athletes
challenge each person with questions the
other side but I do enjoy it and I know
it was out totally out of context but
that person like why you're asking these
questions and because you're just
putting it in top of everyone's mind so
every so many things that are being
forced down our throats we are that or
topics not even just this but any topic
and when we question it like kovid we
talked about it yesterday how you bang
bang bang we were being forced and we
lived in Massachusetts and specifically
in Boston where the rules were
ridiculous it was so archaic and um but
if you questioned it you're bad like
don't bring something up if we can't
question it give me a break so that
that's my whole immediate reaction to
why are you questioning me you can't
question anything yeah yeah but you know
what you can and we will and we must we
must continue to I have to say should
trans athletes compete against
biological women people think that
they're gonna beat them and they're
probably not the best for that
competition that's like saying like
there's like 10 bears that are all
fighting each other and then it's like
wait let's bring in this one T-Rex and
then let's add that in and let's see how
that kind of goes and what happens let's
not call it a T-Rex destroys trans
people are T-rexes I mean you can say
that women's sports is pretty
self-descripted women compete against
women no matter how many surgery a
woman's body is a woman's body you can't
really change that you get on hormone
therapy it does change the hormones
within your bodies if you're classified
as females they should be able to
compete against females who do I
actually think yeah women should compete
against women in transgenders should
compete against transgenders why do you
believe them I got my own problems I was
in the military was it fair for a male
to do the female PT test the woman's PT
like a lower standard significantly
lower because a female can only do so
much I do play men's volleyball though
collegiately but before we continue good
that's actually I'm not the only one
confused I hope you don't mind me asking
but were you born in a biological male
I'm non-binary yes I can be female as a
gender and my effect can be male
whatever feels best for the day okay how
about between Monday and Friday uh
Monday and Friday definitely see her at
my job it just depends on the defense
yeah yeah on this channel we explore
though gives us only through genuine
conversations that we can change your
perspective but will people be too
afraid to speak their truth and with all
the controversy will I be demonetized or
even worse cancel like Chappelle bro
chill ain't no one canceling you with
you no subscriber had asked I guess we
gonna see what is a woman then uh anyone
who identifies as such it's just
somebody who feels comfortable within
femininity I don't even want to say
femininity because it goes beyond that
I'm more of a logical person kind of
actually take that weird Jordan Peterson
type stuff just believing in yourself
and actually affect that towards like
gender maybe let's take like a recent
controversial issue like abortion or
women say hey no one should be making
laws about us in that instance it seems
like a woman is someone who is now just
like putting on some lipstick in women's
clothing nobody's got nobody still
hasn't a good answer here they don't
have an answer you identify as a woman
but what is a woman as a it's a woman
you have a baby does that can situate a
woman or would you still stick with your
definition a uterus wouldn't like make
you a woman I feel like there's so many
other parts that are so much more
important than just that vagina
considers a woman but if you have like
the long hair if you have the nails so I
think those are pretty big differences
right because I could put on nails and
hair but if I identified as a woman
would that make me a woman
yeah is there any scientific definitions
or is it just the words become true no
one decides to become a woman a woman so
no one just wakes
oh I feel like being a woman yes that's
exactly what they're doing then what is
it that's exactly what they're doing we
just said depending on how I feel
throughout the week I can be a woman I
can be a man what's I don't understand
that they don't have any thought there
is no logic there's no there's no logic
behind it it's whatever what are you
gonna do and even social repercussions
like this entire line of question
come with coming out as a woman but
wouldn't that be kind of ignoring some
sort of biological uh I don't know
realities I think that everybody has
their own biological reality and that's
how the world has always worked but this
world is changing every [ __ ] day and
you just gotta keep up with the new time
are you straight by chance I am yeah you
identify as straight and you identify as
a male yeah so not everybody's gonna
follow what your path is and some people
have their own path and sometimes we
just weren't born with that knowledge
because we didn't got taught that whoa
those are some badonkadonks right you
know they're not real right they are and
by that I don't I don't mean that
they're implants I mean it's a it's like
a a sort of a suit I mean you can see
look at the right side you can literally
see the suit coming off she's probably
pissed that you could see it there
because that she shouldn't be standing
with her arms behind her back but yeah
it's just it I mean it's a suit I know
they come in and you can actually use
makeup to like cover to make the seams
it's like sci-fi makeup holy [ __ ] but as
a children why has it changed over the
last few years it is trans men who are
now capable of giving birth whatever
makes someone feel better
level of giving birth there's a women
people with a vagina and a uterus giving
birth that's it just because you think
you're a man on the ins in your brain
doesn't make you a man giving birth I
mean I can't stand this and now they're
out there talking about calling mothers
birthing people so I'm a birthing person
because there's like you know a half a
dozen men somewhere in the United States
just half a dozen women dressed as men
having kids that you know we all have to
be called birthing people no sorry I'm
still a mother and I'm going to
celebrate Mother's Day and I better get
a gift on Mother's Day because that's
who I am period things that matter to
anybody okay so then what would the
other side say okay in your mind do you
think there are more than two genders
yes
I couldn't identify them all for you but
I'm an old school so if I'm growing up
others again I think I decided that I'm
an alien do you believe me and if you
don't accept that I'm an alien then
you're wrong and that just doesn't make
logical sense you can have your own
opinion your own thoughts but I think
there's one or the other outside of
sport I don't really think it matters so
obviously both sides have opinions but
do both sides have Solutions what do you
think is a solution yeah I can tell you
that do you think a lot of friends who
are based and they just for different
reasons they don't want to be on the uh
they don't speak out on social media but
maybe their husband works you know for
the state or they work for the city or
they just do they have a good a high
profile job in the private sector and
they just don't want to rock the boat
because they've seen so many people get
fired so unfortunately it's just
starting to happen now where people are
tired of being silenced and they're
speaking out that's why they're out
there yeah it's kakajul what are you
gonna do yeah Sports should be gender
neutral I've seen some females out there
that can kick any guy's ass I mean look
at [ __ ] Ronda Rousey she could
probably take all her asses up at once I
don't know she could get a lot of asses
yeah she couldn't get a lot of acid she
goes against anyone in the UFC though
and they'll break her face yes yes right
she can kick a lot of regular dudes
non-fight non-trained fighter dudes
asses like wow Serena Williams could
could beat the community center tennis
player's ass she should go against the
best tennis players in the world no yeah
nope it's just annoying not at all but
do you think she'll be able to take
April UFC fighter I mean look at her
that [ __ ] is vicious you know what I
mean honestly I feel like you could beat
my ass with those honestly baby I'll
give somebody a black guy with these
some women probably think that they're
like faster than men and some men
probably think that they do like way
better in like a female or I'm trying to
think of one that typically females are
in oh cheerleading yeah I think that's
the only way you could do it without
pissing people off should our priority
be to not wait did he just did he just
agree that there should be gender
neutral Sports is that what I don't know
I was stuck on the cheerleading thing
for a second so when cheerleading in in
college Collegiate High School is very
serious cheerleading there are men and
the men you know pick up the girls and
they're typically the smallest girls are
the Tumblers that go to the you know
that go away to the top of the pyramids
so now you've got you know Frank from
the 11th Court he decides he wants to
put on a dress and you've got it and he
wants to Tumble like like Trina and jump
to the top of the pyramid when he weighs
twice as much what's happening piss
people off
um
yeah that it is tricky I guess you have
to choose who you want to piss off
because then you create more division
right and you say oh well we're gonna
make this only but then it does make it
inclusive for them if that's what they
want to do so they're going to be in the
company not necessarily but I think if
we're going to talk about integration
people of color being integrated into
our schools Park Society wasn't
normalized until we talked about it so
tram is one of those topics right now
that we just have to normalize we're not
[ __ ] again we
uh nobody cares if you're trans let it
be let me normalize to normalize
something I don't even know exactly what
they mean by that but it does not have
to make it commonplace we can be
tolerant and accepting and kind to
people and it doesn't have to be
commonplace and we don't have to try to
try to convince a bunch of school
children that they might be trans or
they are trans just to make this Fringe
population feel like there's more of me
and I'm not alone anymore it's [ __ ]
ridiculous and to act like that's act
like the actual motive it's not even the
motive behind all these these big media
companies the actor gets to include the
trans people that's why they if they
make Trends kids show characters like
that's not why you're doing that yeah
let's ignore the fact that they that
they have the highest suicide rate of
any population of humans and let's make
more people let's put more people into
that category let's do that okay
two or three times as hard to try to
compete against someone naturally born
as a male which does bring up something
that no one wants to talk about are
trans women taking away women's rights
because it wasn't until 50 years ago
when Title IX granted more equal access
to women in sports but today when a
trans woman receives a roster spot is it
denying biological women's opportunities
if there are biological advantages more
times than not is a denying opportunity
to win I think you have to ask that
population if only I knew someone who
was trans
or developing natural testosterone
they're not as strong as me should there
be an age cut often yes they're estrogen
and testosterone levels have to be
tested before competing if I'ma be real
I didn't expect that answer and that
even with hormone therapy when you
transition matters so let's explore
further on these things
the determining factor of whether you're
a man or a woman that is not it it's not
just about people like oh the hormones
it's the hormones it's all I know it's
not all about the hormones it's about
your skeleton and your muscles and your
lung capacity and your heart capacity
and the way your body works that has
nothing to do with hormones men have
bigger muscles they're naturally taller
more mass does women have any sort of
Advantage again when it comes to
Sports no people can train and become
Professionals in whatever sport that
they wanted
some people grow muscle faster than
others and that has nothing to do with
your gender
General do you think men and women have
physical differences I think there are
physical differences across the plain we
have differences we're both women we
have differences we're both women
yeah there could be biological
advantages to it but at what point is
like that measure quantifiable a
basketball player is scoring 500 points
a game I would say that would go into
more skill than rather than just like
hormonal like insolence as long as
they're on the ground they're so
brainwashed into believing that it's all
about the hormones it's unbelievable
it's like they got a hormone flyer and
they and they all read it and that's all
they know about yeah I actually think at
that point it becomes a disadvantage I
am awesome I lost a lot of that muscle
gained a lot of fatigue when I used to
play soccer and I felt like it was like
better I felt like I could challenge
myself more it said that it made you
better are you saying that men have an
advantage over women when it comes to
sports uh no I don't think so there's
like ways in which that men and women
can learn from each other and
I guess but could that be considered a
bit unfair for biological women I don't
think you know who LeBron James is so
he's 6A 280 pounds what if he became a
trans woman and competed against WNBA
players would that be something that the
WNBA players should just get over like
she would have an advantage at the same
time I don't know I feel like they could
figure it out yeah you'll say anything
to stick to your point anything they
will say that LeBron James should figure
it out in the WNBA and it would be
A-Okay she'll say they will say anything
to just to drive from their point into
not even consider another perspective
she just sounded like an absolute
dumbass I feel bad making for like like
you're right I should be a better
Christian I'm really trying and not
being very good right now I'm not you're
right we should feel bad yeah
it's always similarly stacked women
there are six foot plus women who weigh
a lot who have a lot of musculature
um and probably they'd be playing in the
same league I think it would just depend
on the sport I guess what would be a
sport where it would be an equal playing
field I haven't really thought too much
about it I think in swimming it's
possible because they're likely to be
more muscular and it's something that's
actually happened Leah Thomas was what
maybe Billiards shooting pool maybe
that's like one of the only things that
maybe we could have some Equity uh what
else there's got to be something else
even with like chess all the billiards
billiards is you know Market in sport
right I don't know exactly how it's
categorized even chess which did you say
chess I was gonna say even like the top
chess players in the world are men so
even things that you wouldn't think
would like gender would play a role in
it does that could be though especially
um really that women being girls I
should say being encouraged to go into
uh stem Fields science technology do you
think it's just because there's more
dudes overall playing chess so obviously
men are men have like generations of
being taught mathematics and science
ahead of women so we are behind the
curve just because of you know the way
you are so our Evolution has our social
and economic Evolution has a card if
your grandma got taught math you'd be
better at it what no I think I think it
I think it does make a difference when
you're just you know having you know
younger Generations so there's going to
be say okay look at me okay here's
here's a good example um I wasn't
allowed to play sports because it wasn't
really for girls and I I wanted to be a
carpenter and I wasn't allowed to be a
carpenter because it wasn't for girls my
mother in this 60s was you know before
well before I was born they were the you
know suit and and uh A-line skirt couple
a nice dress they weren't the
hippy-dippy people who were like pushing
Progressive so my parents still had a
50s mindset where other other parents of
the same age had a totally different
mindset and they were pushing girls so
now you had half of us and this half of
us in this so there were only half of
the population of young girls was like
learning more things that men were and
getting into sports as the generations
went on there was more and more and more
of us so are you following are you
catching where I'm going you know so
there's not going to be as many good
female chess players because of that I
feel really I feel like you know what
I'm saying and we're get we're getting
there and and I think that that when I
hear women complaining about there
aren't enough women's CEOs well again
the women that are at age to be CEOs 40s
50s 60s like the men there aren't as
many of us that were taught that even
taught how to be team players you know I
had to learn how to be a team player on
my own I was in ballet class it was do
or die you weren't enough you weren't
you know there was some team in in a
performance but you were really just
doing your own make worrying about your
own performance yeah a lot of the more
feminine activities you didn't learn
those kinds of stuff they were much more
of like an individual sports so to use
the word Loosely so that was the real
question so I didn't learn about
teamwork and I didn't learn about
leadership until I got older and I had
to learn it on my own that's why there
were more men as as we go through
generations it might change and I think
it's going to change and I think that
everybody complaining and just giving
women leadership roles that aren't
equipped for it is idiotic it was a
swimmer at UPenn who started her
collegiate career competing on the men's
swim team but during Leah's junior year
she started hormone therapy and
transition to be happy previously Leo
was raised 65th in the men's five yard
freestyle but as a woman thank you Tom
is pulling away over the final one 150
meters
she ranked first after winning the
National Championship it's controversy
to even questioned this but Sports is
competition So to avoid falling behind
will more programs start exclusively
recruiting trans athletes you know
completely it's something the world
swimming organization has noticed new
rules will now only allow athletes why
wouldn't you just if you really wanted
to win why wouldn't you just recruit all
trans athletes you'd smoke every other
school yeah yeah just bring a bunch of
dudes to the onto the men's team onto
yeah onto the women's team do they have
this in the Olympics can guys complete
and compete in women's sports or are
they are they still have somewhat of a
brain
[ __ ] on bug like I'm a big soccer fan
soccer becoming competitive to the point
where like some of them are like passing
the same like records at the same time I
have to disagree I well because I have
personal experiences with this when I
was like on a u16 soccer team we played
the Portland Thorns so they were like
the Women's Champions of that specific
year so they have like Alex Morgan like
a bunch of like these Olympic high-level
athletes we kill them 6-1 and we were
15. a personal experience like that only
goes so far
that's not the only story like that I've
heard oh my God that's crazy someone
else sent the Super Chat I think even in
sports like darts where you're not
required to be a real physical specimen
men still dominate a woman named silence
your rock has been playing against men
recently and has been beaten easily hmm
interesting interesting all right you
guys have outliers because we're seeing
individual women break like certain
records and all that against other women
it is against other women but we are
also seeing those numbers match very
closely to male numbers don't you think
numbers are always relative right like
let's say if I joined a eight-year-old
League I'm gonna score a thousand goals
yeah right no but numbers as far as like
stuff like goals or like yeah I guess
like what I'm arguing that it is
relative though right because you're
comparing a woman who is playing against
other women's that record against a man
playing against other men right yeah
exactly but those numbers be coming
closer that is also a good sign that
gonna move that like the bell curve
closer and closer together that doesn't
mean anything what is what kind of what
kind of stupid logic is this do you ever
see remember the movie I ever told have
we ever watched it together called bad
words it's so good it's with Jason
Bateman and he he is a grown man like 35
years old and he goes and enters a kid's
spelling bee and he takes the [ __ ] out
all the kids I feel like I have seen
that that sounds funny yeah but maybe he
just identifies as a kid and it sounds
goofy it sounds like it's like a Happy
Gilmore kind of a movie but it's not
it's very it's funny but it's an indie
film so it also is very well done
dramatically highly recommend hmm
physical rigor do you think then trans
woman should be able to compete against
biological women but people wonder why
WNBA and NBA get paid differently it's
because clearly NBA guys are dunking
like crazy but hey if a girl is at that
level then sure like go do it how about
like maybe nothing to do with the dogs
it has to do with ticket sales yeah I
was just gonna say tickets and merch
area to an extent it does have to do
with the dunks in the aspect that that's
what people want to see so then that's
why there are ticket sales that's I
think that's more of what he meant like
obviously it has to do with what the
company's bringing in that's what the
players get paid and that's why and WNBA
players don't get paid
they want to see speed maybe there's a
good video about that we can watch next
WNBA players getting paid people
interviewed about that if we just want
to keep getting angry or Consequences
like UFC or MMA do you think men and
women should be fighting against each
other so I would think the weight
classes could account for that what are
the biological women I think it's unfair
but they still have to compete what
about those instances
I know I would never be trying to piss
Spiderman why is that my opinion doesn't
really matter because I'll never be like
involved in that stuff sorry no you
don't have to apologize if my opinion
doesn't matter oh okay because I'm not
allowed to have an opinion she better be
careful if that's her standard for
everything in life
my ass off every [ __ ] day there's a
guy who doesn't have to train as hard as
me he comes in and he beats me I'm gonna
feel like [ __ ] no and if anyone's a lot
of voice and opinion shouldn't it be
those in competition but instead what
we're seeing is yeah
because at a certain point I felt like I
had to do something Taylor Silverman is
a Jewish skater who plays second in two
different contests to trans women so fed
up she posted a screenshot of her email
to Red Bull who hosted the contest and I
knew that people would come after me I
knew that people would come after me for
being Jewish and what followed was a
viral post with tons of comments calling
her a transphobe and even some
anti-semitic hate the people who are
responsible are the contest organizers
who allow it to happen because the
reality is all the athletes competing
are just going by the rules obviously
emailing Red Bull wasn't a way to start
a conversation about it they did not
want to have that conversation at all
it's exactly this censorship of
discussion I've never even heard of that
that's completely hypocritical to the
totem message it's so disturbing first
of all obviously that the company
wouldn't except it wouldn't wouldn't
even have a have a conversation with her
um I'm most upset about the anti-semitic
comments that she received I mean this
is just a young girl that's right where
they go and this is where you know they
go right for races you know racism and
and going straight you know racism and
whatever religious bias and that's
interesting instead of having an actual
uh disagree you know disagreement and
name-calling these people are backwards
mom but that kind of a hate is it really
disturbs me because you know I grew up
in Brooklyn in a and a half Italian and
half Jewish neighborhood and there were
um a couple people and probably more
than I knew but a couple people that I
knew of who who came from to Brooklyn
after being prisoners in Nazi Nazi camps
and they had numbers the numbers
tattooed on them and I saw that as a
little girl and they weren't my family
because we were Italian but it never
it's really as it grew up and I really
started to understand the severity of
that I get really pissed off with
anti-Semitism oh it's just the red show
I didn't realize is that oh that's all
right what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do it right now
time to explore further because we
because we heard of trans women
competing but why not the reverse why do
we never hear instances of trans men
competing against biological men but
we've heard a lot of instances of trans
women competing against biological women
I am aware of trans professional male
athletes who are successful I haven't
heard any in the NBA or soccer tend to
focus on things that are mainstream we
just don't necessarily get that in the
news as often but we've been hearing
news about trans women competing
men versus women and we can just watch
that stuff but that's fine that's too
grown you can watch that online that's a
thing that's what I that's what I get
out of rating the most liberal College
oh look I'll look out at it next make
sure you if you guys want to suggest
videos you can drop them in my Discord
server this is like and that's how like
this is it operates on clicks do you
think there are instances like why are
you asking these questions right now
type thing oh I'm trying to get closer
to what the answer might be that's why
I'm going this approach uh asking
questions to what the other side may ask
you it's a slightly different approach
and it's like nice is because of
misogyny this is an instance of a
biological women turning into a man
competing against men why would there be
misogyny involved then because
basically they're not taking them
serious so then why do we not see the
reverse do you think it's just one-sided
misogyny or I think it's I literally
think it's that it's if there's no
physiology I just had a really hard time
following that I don't know I was
looking at her what did she say I was
looking at if she had if those are boobs
or or what are those or packs that's
what I was focused when it comes to
sports why haven't we heard any
instances of that Society seems to deem
women's sports as needing some sort of
assistance so when they see a trans
person competing they feel as though
there's something encroaching on a sport
that's already not competing on the same
level as men's sports which is
inaccurate women's sports are highly
competitive often can compete with men
at the same level and win really one
example give one example not even golf
not even golf there are so few women
that can hit a drive as far as a man
maybe in putting they can compete with
each other woman playing against a man
tennis player you can see it being
fairly competitive and in 1998 Serena
and Venus Williams did exactly that
or try to they challenge any
professional male player to match as
long as they were outside of the top
200. the challenge was accepted by
Carson brosh who was ranked 203rd in the
world
200. Serena 6-1 and Venus 6-2 so they
wouldn't even they didn't even have the
cajones or you know whatever it is
ladies have to to say if they're going
to try to prove a point say yeah I want
to I'll I'll play against the top guy
and then they get their asses kicked by
number two they knew that they weren't
were they trying to proof a point is
that what they were doing I think that's
what they were trying to do that's
that's the impression I got but again
okay out of context let's see what she
says big difference worth a minute lot
faster I love to play women's tennis
tonight I only want to play girls
because I don't want to be embarrassed
so now it's time to ask the most
important question it is a question that
I kept asking myself throughout this
video does questioning make you
transphobic no I'm tired of stuck in my
understood I would be lying to myself if
I say anything else I think questioning
is fine because they're allowed to
explore the Curiosity and become much
more understanding I think once you make
a judgment towards it that's when like I
love how this is outside of the top 200
and then they did the 200 third match
you didn't get really too into it but
basically women had a fight very hard
for for the right to have their own
sports and then ultimately you know that
term that was Collegiate Sports and then
that turned into professional sports and
there were some professional female
sports leagues I mean even wasn't there
like a Lingerie Football League and even
that yeah remember my gym my gym teacher
was in that league did that even did
that did that fail I mean or is that
still a thing curious because I don't
know I don't know if it failed but I
know it never blew up to be mainstream
you couldn't even people don't even want
to watch women playing football in hot
lingerie like give me like this is how
much people aren't interested in
watching it but at the same time we as
women should have a right to compete
fairly and and have fun and maybe become
you know well-prayed professionals what
was that show that there used to be
about the dudes coming in and kicking
our asses was that show that there used
to be about the woman coming in and
pitching in the MLB oh that was a cute
show it was about yeah yeah that oh that
was a very cute show yeah it was it was
it was a nice it was like a ABC Family
Show or something like that and it was
they had nice characters and it was all
just this fantasy land about a woman who
came in and produced and pitched Major
League Baseball I was disappointed when
it got canceled because it was like a
feel-good thing when you were a little
kid but again just to feel good fun
little show question if there's no
difference between a man and woman
what's all the fuss about toxic
masculinity and patriarchy we're all
equal then the level yeah yeah you know
what Tanya you're speaking facts and
you're being logical logic has no place
here anymore on this planet none don't
come in it's very cool though when it
comes to sports gotta be black and white
yeah I would watch women so a lot of
people won't agree with do you think
we're prioritizing not pissing people
awesome commentary thank you John yeah
but why because because they're better
players because they just look great on
the beach oh why would I watch women's
volleyball yeah take a [ __ ] guess
yeah exactly okay no I actually meant
volleyball is really good to watch too
though like they they go they [ __ ]
Spike that yeah right but but you're
watching women I'm not watching women's
for the yeah you're not watching it for
the athleticism no accept it or or
desire to be accepted my whole life when
I see something this is what my brain
tells me for me to just say oh that's
this and not understand it that is me
disagreeing with myself and that causes
more conflict within that's also another
line that we have to like really be wary
of things have changed considerably
women didn't look like that
now more than ever we need to learn to
disagree but when questioning the
current thing means you're whatever
phobic how can we even have these types
of conversations where are you from by
the way ladies I got that country was
there when it's in Jamaica now but in
other words probably my opinion it might
be not someone's opinion and even though
I was afraid to make this what I
realized make sure you're getting you're
sitting in the camera curiosity people
will speak their truth and just how
people should have their right to do
whatever they want with their body have
you always felt this way is this always
something that you wanted to do sense
like childhood and I wanted to be viewed
for myself versus like a gender people
should also have the right to speak out
for their beliefs because if there's one
guarantee in the world it's changed
isn't viewed the same way now
maintaining a focus is the same people
that say to follow the science follow
the studies take the vaccine remember
like dude for last I remember 10 years
ago they were saying by like 2022
Climate Change is Gonna like like there
won't be a North America won't be a
thing anymore by two years ago that was
the thing for the longest time I haven't
heard anything about climate change in a
while what do you think the next
election no they're still talking about
it they're supposed to talk about it and
they're still calling it an existential
threat which is again when you speak in
such hyperbole I'm not listening I'm not
listening because you know what I went
food shopping and the meat was 50 more
and I'm pissed about it that's that's a
real threat to my to my lifestyle to my
life yeah what the [ __ ] they're still
talking about it that's what all this
that's what the whole uh inflation
reduction Act was it was it was called
that and it was disguised it was like
great new a bunch of green New Deal
[ __ ] shoved in there is a good thing
navigating change means dealing with the
controversies and it all starts by
exploring the unfamiliar is this gonna
be broadcast yeah Sylveon youtube.com
[Music]